[Music]
here in this video we will discuss about
the life cycle of pacific rim kaijus we
know that they are a race of amphibious
creatures genetically engineered by the
precursors a sentient race from the
antiverse
but that's just from the movies and now
along with the animated series the black
we get more insight to what these
creatures really are their origins their
biology and how they reproduce and their
entire life cycle
so let's separate each step of their
life cycle into brief distinct parts and
get to the crux of it so now let's get
to it
let's start with the origins of this
kaiju not much is really known as to how
they evolved or even came to be as
gigantic monsters but we are led to
believe that they are bio-organic war
machines created by an interdimensional
race of aliens called the precursors it
is possible that these aliens have tried
to colonize earth during the triassic
period millions and millions of years
ago but the climatic conditions were
unfavorable to their existence so when
they tried again in the modern times
they found out that humans with their
technology could be a hindrance to their
plans so they genetically engineered
these sky jews to eradicate humanity
before their arrival but i'm guessing
that they had to base their monstrous
creations on something that evolved
naturally and with non-synthetic
biological traits
so that's their origins as far as we
know now let's talk about the biology of
these kaiju well kaiju are colossal in
size averaging hundreds of feet in
height and thousands of tons in weight
because of their tremendous body mass
two brains are needed to control the
kaiju's motor and cognitive functions
they have varied number of limbs
depending on the species and their skin
is usually thick and armoured their
physiology allows them to adapt and
survive on land and water kaiju can
breathe and survive on land on the
ground on the water and even in space
kaiju are silicon based
their blood called kaiju blue is an
ammonia-based fluid it is highly
corrosive highly toxic to humans and
rapidly vaporizes in air following the
death of the kaiju
so should they be killed in battle their
bodies are triggered to self-destruct
immediately the blood or the flute of a
kaiju is as i said before ammonia base
the kaiju blue has the potential to
poison the air and the surroundings
around it making the land uninhabitable
kaiju's blood is very corrosive
corroding everything in its path this
makes it particularly difficult to
collect samples for testing and
experimentation in a safe manner
although later
when it was successful to collect them
the kaiju blue was utilized and modified
into rocket fuel and can even be used as
explosives and for power generation
so before we go on to the life cycle of
this kaiju let's talk about their
categorization or classification kaiju
have been categorized into different
categories
with categories 1 and 2 representing the
weakest of them while 3 to 5 are the
strongest with a new category 6 seen in
the season 2 of the black classification
is based on size toxicity and radiation
levels given off by their bodies kaiju
are highly aggressive creatures
especially in combat they can combine
with the help of rippers as in the case
of the mega kaiju when two category
fours and one category five kaiju merged
to form this possibly category 6 1 but
then the first confirmed category 6
kaiju is the breacher from season 2 of
the black which seemed to be strong but
then still weaker than slaton or the
mega kaiju even though it is one
category above them
okay so now let's get to the
reproduction and the life cycle of these
kaiju they are stated to be created and
not born their tissue is cloned from a
single strand of tri-helix dna and the
precursors assemble these creatures by
connecting the clone pieces all kaijus
share the same genotype but have widely
varying phenotypes this results in
anatomical similarities between two
different kinds of kaiju as a result of
cloning anyway to put this into simpler
words the precursors are highly advanced
species that use an unknown based
species and experimented with their
trihelix dna and created and cloned
these heads torso limbs and tails of the
kaiju and these parts are not uniform in
size some are bigger than others then
they are then attached in different
sequences and styles to form the
different types and species of the
kaijus we see in the movies and the
series
but kaiju that have been created are not
without the ability to reproduce given
that otachi was pregnant when she landed
on earth but then again it is unclear
whether the reproduction is sexual
hermephroditic or asexual
as the information given by the movies
is limited in season 2 of the black
however mo is revealed it seems that
kaiju were originally asexual but as
they age they develop sexual organs like
actual monster balls
so given the fact that otachi obviously
has ovaries and that she was pregnant
and now that there is evidence for kaiju
testicles during season 2 we can now
clearly say that these creatures
are these kaiju clones have at least two
different sexes but regarding the
differences between the males and
females the sexual dimorphism so to say
is still up to debate as we haven't seen
a male or a female kaiju of the same
species together in the same place
both in the movies and the animated
series we
saw baby kaijus
and even they vary from each other by a
large degree for example the baby otachi
that came out of the dead mother's body
and it was still preformed and yet it
was as big as two elephants while the
baby trespassers that was seen in the
second season of the black were a bit
bigger than a normal human
and it was seen that they were quite a
number of them the baby trespassers in
the show around the same age which means
that a kaiju can have more than one cup
in its litter
even the big trespasser called lucy was
initially found by the crazy dude the
crazy australian as a baby and he reared
her and in just a few years it had grown
to the size of an adult
so we've seen baby kaijus and adult
kaijus but the juvenile stage is yet to
be seen and with the ending of the
animated series we probably wouldn't
but we can say that the kaiju can grow
at an alarming rate growing
exponentially in just a few years from a
six to seven feet tall baby to a 250 to
300 feet tall adult which begs the
question what do they eat to grow
kaijus are mechanical in nature and they
are biological and are seen to be
predators feeding on both other smaller
kaiju and other animals including humans
okay so to put it all in short the life
cycle well these kaijus were originally
created and cloned by the precursors and
even assembled by them part by part
the ones that were released via the
breach to planet earth over time they
developed sexual organs and reproduce
their own young these baby kaijus then
feed on other life forms and grow to an
adult stage in just a few years and that
my friends is the life cycle the entire
life cycle of a kaiju from the pacific
rim
and with that we come to the end of this
video i hope you liked it so
hit that like button for support and
subscribe as well to be a part of the
mind cue family but most of all smash
that bell icon for regular updates on
new videos right here on this channel
till the next one
take care fam